bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne l'audition d'alain
rousset le président de l'association
des régions de france il est entendu par
les sénateurs sur le projet de loi qui
doit permettre la création de la banque
publique d'investissement la fameuse bpi
il va donc se faire le porte parole des
présidents de région qui réclame un réel
poids des régions qu'ils considèrent les
mieux placés pour financer les pme
je vous rappelle en effet que la bpi a
pour objectif justement de financer à
les pme porteuses d'un projet d'avenir
et qu'elle disposera pour cela d'une
force de frappe de 42 milliards d'euros
mais pour alain rousset bien la
condition du succès de la bpi passe par
une régionalisation des décisions tout
de suite donc l'audition d'alain rousset
bonne après midi à tous bien mes chers
collègues nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui monsieur alain
rousset président de la rs enfin pour
ceux qui connaîtraient pas ce qui
m'étonne d'ailleurs je vois un de vos
collègues mon cher ami au premier rang
très assidus sérieux ce qui nous change
de l'ambiance des affaires économiques
d'habitude mais
non mais c'est sous l'impulsion des
bordelais type césar est en tous les cas
ce que je ce qu'on attend sans doute de
vous mais vraiment dire à deux mots
c'est évidemment par rapport au projet
de bpi
quel est le rôle des régions tel qu'il a
été prévu et elle qu' il sort du texte
l'assemblée nationale et de l'accord si
j'ai bien compris que vous avez obtenu
avec le gouvernement obtenus chez pas si
c'est le bon terme mais en tous les cas
l'accord qui est sorti de vos réunions à
l'arraché peut-être bien te dit
l'essentiel bien sûr notre commission du
développement durable de la maison
territoire donc est concerné dans cette
création bien sûr très attendu puisque
c'est finalement le point de départ de
cette mise en oeuvre de la feuille de
route du président de la république d'un
domaine de la transition énergétique et
nous savoir monsieur le président
combien vous vous êtes battus pour que
en fait il ya un ancrage territorial de
cette baie pays puisque évidemment les
régions sont en première ligne quand à
leurs compétences en matière de
développement économique voilà moi nous
savons que vous êtres nombre de
convictions dont nous allons vous
écouter dans vos convictions qui
j'espère ont abouti merci monsieur le
président vous avez seule la parole dans
un premier temps sur l'euro ça me change
eh bien monsieur le président monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues et
cher ami d'abord peut-être d'abord
peut-être brossé le tableau de ce qui
existe au haut niveau des régions parce
que ça motive notre notre réflexion et
nos choix en gros les régions mis en
place 800 dispositifs d'apport en fonds
propres et de garanties pour les
entreprises à l'échelle de la france
plus ou moins développés selon les
régions selon les les tropismes des
différents allumé 800 avec la caisse des
dépôts d'une part et puis parce que nous
sommes dans un système dit pareil pas su
avec
avec le privé jeu des systèmes
interrégionaux ma région avec
midi-pyrénées
si dispositif en commun ce qui permet
d'arriver à des interventions de l'ordre
en fonds propres de 2 3 ou 4 millions
d'euros on commence par ce que les
spécialistes appellent la love money le
prêt d'honneur le ti près que ce soit en
économie sociale mais un chercheur qui
va lancer sa start up jusqu'au 2e au 3e
tour de table premier de deux
difficultés en difficulté pour faire
croître le capital de ces fonds
d'investissement et pour arriver à des
tic est important or aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin les entreprises ont besoin
pardon d'avoir des décisions rapides et
de au montant le modèle californien qui
est un modèle assez intéressant mais en
place des dispositifs de financement de
50 100 millions de dollars très vite
j'ai réparé des technologues capable de
comprendre les aspects de la finance
donc on a nous ce dispositif les régions
françaises sont-elles qu'aujourd'hui on
est limité mais à un moment donné vous
avez une entreprise du médicament qui en
est à son 2e au 3e tour de table qui va
demander 40 à 50 millions d'euros
et on peut pas leur fournir
donc il ya quelque chose mais la france
un retard des règles en matière de fonds
d'investissement terrible parce que
l'assurance vie qui pourrait être un
élément d'accompagnement ne ne coule pas
directement avec les règles de solvency
2 vers l'est dans les entreprises parce
que les fonds sont disséminés parce que
nous n'avons pas cette tradition et un
temps on a besoin de ces pneus de ses
fonds propres
donc l'enjeu de la de la bpi pour nous
c'est sur le territoire à partir des
dossiers que l'on gère déjà en
investissement en avance remboursable en
aide à l'innovation en aide à la
formation dans les gens comme la mienne
ces 1500 euros 1500 souvent 1500
dossiers par an une région comme
rhône-alpes 3500 je sais pas combien
alain le vern a dans sa région mais
celle des montants donc c'est nous qui
allons apporter ces dossiers donc ça
c'est le l'élément de démarrage la
connaissance du tissu des pme
la connaissance de leurs besoins le fait
qu'elles ont si on veut faire croître
les pme pour arriver à des deux pays et
donc réindustrialiser la france
il faut ouvrir le capital ce avec eux on
les entreprises ne croise enfin la part
de financement capitaux propres des
entre des pme des noeuds qu'elle n'est
que de quatre et demi pourcent 0,5 sur
les marchés monétaires et 95% par la
dette
donc ce voile à ce dispositif et on
intervient un peu comme banquier aussi
les avances remboursables
c'est les prêts à taux zéro quelques pas
et quand on garantit en a les
dispositifs avec oseo donc notre
première demande aux régions des régions
a été de proposer un dispositif à
l'allemande
les länder sont les lander son
actionnaire de référence des landes deux
banques et caisses d'épargné allemandes
qui sont eux-mêmes l'actionnaire de
référence des hôtes également le modèle
vertueux ont certes s'il ya des
difficultés parfois dans les caisses
d'épargné allemandes mais en gros le
modèle vertueux qui fait que l'épargné
dirait vers l'entreprise une
identification une reconnaissance du
tissu industriel une petite révolution
culturelle chez nos concitoyens est une
vraie démarche industrielle à l'échelle
de la rue donc c'est la proposition que
nous avons faite un système mutualiste
des banques publiques régionales
d'investissement
ça n'a pas été retenue par bercy et donc
on a essayé de trouver un compromis
ce compromis fait que le ministre l'a
évoqué 90 % des des dossiers devraient
être décidées au niveau régional je
l'espère parce que c'est la banque
elle-même le futur banques elles-mêmes
qui mettra en place ces dispositifs de
délégation de pouvoirs aux équipes
territoriales
d'où l'importance que nous soyons dans
ses équipes
alors là il ya un point sur lequel je
voudrais faire une incidente qui est
importante je suis pour ma part surpris
et avec mes collègues humilié de
l'attitude de beaucoup de nos collègues
parlementaires je l' ai vécu à
l'assemblée nationale je pense que ça
sera pas le cas au sénat sur le fait
avec six nations ouais je fais une
préparation d'artillerie comme en 14
sur le fait que nous serions au mieux
clientélisme avant au mieux incompétent
au pire clientéliste
comme si depuis vingt ans et notamment
depuis 2004 nous avons la dévolution de
la compétence y nomme innovation nous
n'allions nous aidions les canards
boiteux ou alors nous faisions des jeux
or que je sache les 800 dispositifs que
nous avons mis en place aucun est en
difficulté aucun est en difficulté et
mis en place par les conseils régionaux
je rappelle que les sdr était dirigé par
des banquiers
je vous évite le fait qu'on évoque ici
les sdr en disant mais regardez les sdr
on était en difficulté les sdr était
dirigé par des banquiers dans le modèle
bancaire que nous connaissons en france
les banques qui ont des difficultés ont
tout pardonnez moi l'expression pourrit
par la tête tout toutes les opérations
d'adhérence en grèce du crédit agricole
les opérations de dexia les problèmes de
la société générale aucune caisse
régionale n'a été en difficulté pour une
raison très simple et très grave d'une
certaine manière c'est qu'on remonte
tous les excédents de placement au
niveau national qui sont placés en
produits structurés dans le monde entier
et donc par rapport à mon modèle
allemand que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
nous ne gardons pas ses disponibilités
pour les flécher un l'appareil productif
nous avons une insuffisance
d'accompagnement de l'appareil productif
et aujourd'hui il faut que les régions
soient dans le les centres de décision
peut-être pas les présidents moi je vais
pas le temps de présider un comité
d'engagement mais mes collaborateurs qui
traite déjà le dossier d'innovation le
dossier d'investissement matériel le
dossier de formation toute une partie
des besoins des pme doivent participer
parce que c'est la connaissance des pm
qu'ils ont et que ce sont des
professionnels et qu'à aucun moment on
met dit la cour des comptes
les chambres régionales les analyses que
nous ne faisons pas bien le job que
l'état et enfin plutôt le pain les par
le parlement nous avait confié il ya 25
ou 30 ans ce job est fait et je peux
vous dire que pendant la crise une
région comme la mienne avec des pme sous
traitantes de l'aéronautique ou les
grands groupes pourra contracter d'un
coup leur appel leur appel d'offres la
dévolution de plan de charge
si nous n'avions pas mis en place
immédiatement des dispositifs d'avancés
remboursables de plusieurs millions en
gros moi je sais que pour mes sous
traitants ça m'a coûté 25 à 30 millions
d'euros
si nous ne les avons pas mis en place
n'étaient pas des entreprises en
difficulté mais il y avait un à coup de
commandes elles auraient aidé belle
coulée
tant que je le dis parce que je les dis
à l'assemblée nationale de la même
manière je n'arrive pas à comprendre que
nos collègues élus nationale disant tous
quelle que soit leur sensibilité il faut
une volonté politique nationale pour
redresser la france ne comprennent pas
qu'il faille aussi une volonté politique
régionale pour faire des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire et mes chers
collègues je vous invite à comparer
notre modèle administratif et notre
modèle industriel
le modèle administratif c'est un état
qui en
énormément de puissance qui peut tout
faire intervenir partout on se plaint
d'ailleurs de danse
même avec un état tentaculaire qu'il ya
des inégalités dans les territoires on
revendique l'égalité mais bon et puis le
modèle industriel des grands groupes et
les pme voire des tpe locos les deux
modèles sont homothétique parce que
notre culture notre organisation reste
profondément centralisée et jacobine là
où il y a des régions fortes
il y à des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire forte ah oui à des länder
il ya des mythes holstein là où il n'y a
pas de régions fortes
il n'y a pas de thé parce que c'est une
volonté politique une volonté politique
qui qui est extrêmement complexe comment
vous faites pour qu'une pme devienne une
taille si ce n'est en l'accompagnant
fonds propres en l'accompagnant
formation en l'aidant à se réorganiser
en l'aidant à haskell et des garanties à
ce qu'elle fasse de la croissance
externe ou de la croissance interne en
l'aidant pendant les périodes de
difficultés en l'accompagnant dans les
discussions qui avaient que les grands
groupes
quand une fois je cite bon exemple mais
je pense qu'alain le vern pourrait faire
de même je suis en train de prendre avec
des grands groupes d aquitaine la liste
des pme sous traitantes et nous sommes
en train de choisir les pme qui
deviendront demain
ces entreprises de taille intermédiaire
par des regroupements par des aides à
l'embauché
parce que c'est un problème majeur et
les régions tous les outils pour ça
alors bien sûr que les régions sont pas
au même niveau d'intervention
mais comment faire avancer toutes les
régions même au même pas si on ne les si
on ne leur confie pas cette
responsabilité doux d'où la nécessité
que l'on préside les conseils régionaux
d'orientation et je ne vois pas dans le
texte
je les ai évoqué à l'assemblée que nous
y soyons naturellement alors qu'il
l'était dans le projet du gouvernement
donc je compte sur vous mes chers
collègues sénateurs pour que vous voulez
remettiez que je
imaginons que demain il y ait des
candidatures comme ça tous azimuts
je crois qu'il faut comme on l'a fait
pour le conseil national d'orientation
il faut que les conseils régionaux soit
soit présidée sur les comités
d'engagement alors là c'est une levée de
boucliers de tout le monde bon après
tout je encore une fois sur le contrôle
de d'alain le vern
à titre personnel je ne préside pas les
comités d'engagement je préside pas les
comités d'engagement mais quand je
préside la commission permanente
je fait voter des aides directes aux
entreprises alors là c'est autre chose
on regarde les entreprises d'une autre
manière
je m'en remets à la sagesse du parlement
dans ce domaine ainsi je peux me
permettre
mais en tout cas il faut que la région
soit présente à travers peut-être un de
ses techniciens obligatoirement dans ces
comités d'engagement parce que le
dossier de la pme est unique
la connaissance de la paix m une fois
qu'on l'aura que le comité d'engagement
de la bpi aura décidé il s'en lavera les
mains et il espère avoir fait une bonne
affaire
sauf que les services de la région vont
accompagner cette entreprise parce
qu'une pme a besoin d'être accompagné je
sors de l'assemblée générale des pôles
de compétitivité
je disais que ce métier qui fait qu'on
est d'une entreprise allait lever des
fonds quand la compagne pour penser son
marché pour structurer son produit pour
enfin on a des équipes à disposition qui
accompagnent les pme le chef
d'entreprise de 35 50 70 personnes il
est souvent drh directeurs de recherche
développement directeur du design
directeur du commerce international je
veux dire comment pouvez-vous vous
débrouiller tout seul surtout si vous
êtes en difficulté
donc il y a à mettre en place un système
d'accompagnement et la france a pris
beaucoup de retard dans ce domaine là
l'idéologie de l'administration centrale
c'est surtout on laisse faire après tout
on attend que les entreprises naissent
et se développent
oui generis et si elle ne se développe
pas ma foi c'est qu'elles sont pas
bonnes
rappelez-vous les discours traditionnels
des banquiers tous ceux qui ont exercé
des responsabilités au niveau
territorial on trouve le financement
quand il ya des bons projets mais bien
entendu vous avez les fcpr aujourd'hui
les fonds communs de placement à risque
qu'ils ne prennent que la crème des
dossiers avec des retours de 25 30 100 %
parfois c'est vrai quand vous êtes dans
un espèce de blockbusters technologique
vous avez les rentrées qui sont
conciliables qu'est ce qui nous importe
nous sur les territoires c'est d'aider
des entreprises aussi à se développer
qui ont 3 4% de marge et la force de
l'allemagne c'est aussi de jouer la
durée c'est de l'argent patients c'est
les retours qui sont pas immédiats donc
c'est cette déontologie que je voudrais
faire passer dans la banque
voilà donc aujourd'hui il ya un problème
de gouvernance qui est peut-être un
problème plus prégnant qui nous concerne
nous région que je trouve un peu
désagréable un peu un peu contradictoire
avec tout ce qui marche bien à
l'extérieur
encore une fois je dis pas que tout se
passe bien et que ya pas d erreur en vie
mais si vous ne responsabilise et pas
les régions
rien ne se passera la bpi si ce n'est
que le rapprochement entre oseo et le
fsi ne réglera strictement rien ne
réglera strictement rien le fsi
c'est une volonté politique territoriale
et des moyens d'accompagner les pme et
de les faire croître si cette volonté
politique territoriale n'a pas une
autorité
ça ne marchera pas c'est très clair on
aura des techniciens dont un
fonctionnement silo comme d'habitude
cette fascination que nous avons à
l'égard des expertises ont certes le
monde politique et bailly sur majorité
de l'entreprise mais on peut progresser
on peut s'entourer techniciens qui font
le job
voilà donc je crois qu'il ya ce problème
de gouvernance il ya un certain nombre
d'évolutions qui aurait été obtenu avec
le ministre notamment que le président
du cn au ce que le la parité un peu
complexifier les choses j'ai réussi à
obtenir qui a trois régions dans le
conseil national d'orientation compliqué
y compris les non voilà donc gros mais
il fallait noms sont pour être désignés
par décret donc on va peut-être mais
voilà je serais si je si si je suis
président de conseil national
d'orientation membres avec voix
consultative du conseil d'administration
j'ai fait en sorte qu'il ya un équilibre
en de petites ou grandes régions mais
c'est surtout au niveau territorial que
cet important
donc voilà je pense que je me remets à
votre sagesse sur le comité d'engagement
il avait été signé avec le président de
la république que les régions présidait
le comité d'engagement
je sais que bercy avait essayé de
détricoter tout ça j'entends l'appareil
technique de bercy en disant où là on va
faire présidée par les présidents de
région des comités de les techniciens
appel de fonds de fonds c'est à dire on
va mettre pour les entreprises du
numérique temps on va mettre et qu'on ne
verrait pas passer les dossiers système
de fonds de fonds c'est vous avez une
capacité puis vous avez un fonds pour le
un fonds pour l'agroalimentaire avait un
fond pour les biotechnologies etc et
vous ne voyez pas passer les dossiers
je crois qu'il faut que la région il ya
quelqu'un de la région qui soit dans le
comité donc d'engagement ça me semble
être le minimum
ça me semble être le minimum est ce que
le risque c'est quoi c'est que nos
dispositifs si nous voyons que nous ne
sommes pas dans le film de la décision
et bien au dispositif on les garde
je ne peux pas être plus franc voilà je
répondrai aux questions mais peut-être
que je vais prendre d'abord les deux
rapporteurs de nos deux commissions
monsieur bourque a d'abord ensuite
monsieur vers eto'o et monsieur le
président le vern
monsieur burqa oui quelques mots un pur
bombe pour dire que faisons en sorte que
ce cette création d'une banque publique
d'investissement soit un des leviers
décisifs pour faire en sorte que comment
le le problème récurrent de fonds
propres qu'on les pme tpe et les deux
pays
je dis pas soit réglé d'un coup de
baguette magique mais quand se dote d'un
levier décisif pour régler ce problème
qu'on régulièrement nos entreprises
l enjeu est là la rousselle à 10 ans en
comme en introduction il ya un enjeu
majeur aujourd'hui
et lorsque nous avons régulièrement des
rencontres avec ces pme tpe
ils nous signalent ses problèmes et ses
lacunes qu'on nous entreprises à se
financer sur le marché tel qu'il existe
la deuxième chose faisons en sorte aussi
que la création de la bpi ne soit pas
l'occasion pour les banques généralistes
de de faire en sorte que les risques
soient pris par la bpi et que le
meilleur soit pris par les banques et
sur le marché faisons en sorte que
justement que la création de la bpi soit
l'occasion d'avoir un vrai levier et que
ça entraîne y compris l'ensemble du
secteur bancaire
ça c'est une vraie question je partage
complètement le fait
que les régions ont un savoir faire
elles ont des liens extrêmement étroits
avec les communautés de communes avec
les communautés d'agglomération et que
ce savoir-faire soient utilisés à sa
juste dimension
effectivement je crois que dans le
comité national de 2 comment
d'orientation il y a eu sans doute par
erreur jo seule chose poche la
suppression de la disposition prévoyant
que le président du conseil régional est
aussi président du comité régional
d'orientation de la bpi faut réparer
cette erreur là elle sénat est là pour
cela
pour ceux là pour faire en sorte que
comment nous nous réparions et nous
faisons en sorte que l' expertise des
régions
l'expérience des régions mais quand je
dis les régions c'est pas simple il est
bien sûr il ya le comité régional le
conseil régional
mais il ya aussi le territoire et moi
j'ai apprécié ce qu'a dit alain rousset
c'est les les économies qui sont hyper
centralisé ont des problèmes parce
qu'elles sont donnés des grands
programmes il ya quelques dizaines
d'années
elle fonctionne encore sur ces grands
programmes et nous avons besoin d'une
économie moderniser où justement les
territoires vont chercher les leviers de
croissance où ils sont et sur la base de
ces leviers de croissance
eux ont investi on prend des risques et
on fait en sorte de retrouver une
nouvelle croissance
celle que nous cherchions depuis des
années et regardez ce qui se passe en
allemagne regarder ce qui se passe dans
plusieurs pays européens
la croissance ira chercher non pas
simplement sur des grands programmes
mais aussi sur des pme tpe qui ont
besoin de vielles qui ont besoin de
financement
alors voila moi je franchement la
position que je défendrai c'est que le
texte transmis au sénat
soit un point d'équilibré satisfaisant
c'est à dire permettre justement à
corriger l'erreur qui a été faite et je
crois que l'expertisé et le savoir-faire
des régions et des territoires soient
pris en compte dans la mise en place de
l'abbaye merci monsieur vers et aux deux
fois allumé rouge merci je je je partage
ce qui a été indiqué par par mon
collègue bourquin sur l'enjeu décisif
qui s'attache à la création de la bpi en
termes d'accès à la ressource bancaire
et aux fonds propres pour le pmi et pme
c'est clair que l'un des objectifs
essentiels de la bpi ce qui est la clé
de sa réussite
c'est cette coordination entre j'allais
dire l'échelon central l'échelon
régional a vu que effectivement lançons
le dispositif que vous avez évoquées
puissent s'inscrire dans une logique
globale d'appui à l'économie locale jeu
dans le rapport que je présenterai
demain devant la commission des blancs
durable je proposerai également que l'on
rétablisse ce qui est effectivement à
mon sens une erreur que le comité
régional soit présidée par le président
effectivement de région pour montrer
effectivement toute la place que doit
tenir la région dans l'irrigation du
tissu et économique
alors si j'ai bien compris vous
souhaitez que les régions et la
responsabilité d'animer les plates
formes communes qui sont qui sont les
guichets uniques de financement pour les
pme
ce qui vaut une demande de
figurer dans les dix dans la structure
d'engagement à mais est ce à dire que
compte tenu de la diversité des régions
vous souhaitez que la composition des
comités des comités régionaux
d'orientation soit adaptée à chaque
territoire
ça me paraît être une question
importante et et d'autre part vous vous
dites que conseil d'adminstration de bp
il serait souhaitable qu'il y ait 3 3
représentants de la région
est ce à dire qu'il faut augmenter le
nombre d'administrateurs ou est-ce que
les roues l'effectif de rester constant
merci oui mais peut-être écouter le
président le vern et puis vous
répondrais oui merci merci monsieur le
président oui je voudrais illustré
encore plus que vient de dire le
président rousset et remercié les deux
collègues sénateurs de leur intervention
complètement pertinente mais si vous
voulez bien je vais insister sur
d'autres points d'abord à mon avis ja
président et elle met rousset je crois
qu'il nous faudrait dans la discussion
et dans les semaines qui viennent mettre
cela en parallèle avec la loi de
décentralisation et
le chef de file à de la région si je
prends l'actualité du président de la
région autrement dit que je connais un
petit peu il y a quelques jours le
président de renault
demandez à la région demandé d'apporter
une aide remboursable de 12 millions
d'euros 0 % en bourse à bled moins un
sur quatre ans pour la fabrication des
moteurs électriques la semaine quelques
jours après le président d'areva demandé
à la région haute-normandie de
l'accompagner sur une filière éolienne
offshore dont vous savez que elle va
être demain en tout cas nous l'espérons
tous une filière d'excellence nouvelles
filières d'excellence de pour notre pays
avec véritablement des perspectives
d'exportation et quand on regarde ce
qu'il y a évidemment dans le montage
industriel de ces deux projets que je
prends par hasard mais c'est le
calendrier qui veut ça ce sont à chaque
fois des centaines de pme qui vont être
concernés parce que évidemment elles
vont être les fournisseurs bon et
comment est-ce qu'on aborde le tissu des
pme qui vont donc être créatrice
d'emplois qui évidemment sont déjà ou
bien elles sont dans l'excellence pour
fournir ses grands projets ou bien elles
vont avoir
il va y avoir nécessité de les
accompagner dans une marge de progrès à
travers un conventionnement global qui
touche à la fois la ressource humaine
qui touche à la fois des aides
matérielles et immatérielles et donc on
le voit bien ce dont on parle c'est pas
simplement la mise en place d'un
établissement public bpi c'est la façon
dont la france va appréhender
sur le marché mondial une nouvelle
époque qui est une époque où on doit
reconquérir des positions sur le terrain
industriel la haute normandie
aujourd'hui c'est un salarié sur cinq
qui travaillent pour l'industrie contre
13% en france à peu près donc
on le voit bien ce tissu industriel là
il faut l'accompagner
quelle est la réalité d'aujourd'hui bien
je vous le dis on vient voir le
président de la région qui va donc
individualisé en commission permanente
des fonds de la région sans que je n'ai
excusez-moi de du raccourci
d'autorisation a demandé à personne sauf
à mon assemblée et à la commission
permanente et donc ce qui me fera
beaucoup dans le projet de loi que j'ai
lu attentivement il se trouve que c'est
mon vice-président à l'économie qui est
le rapporteur du budget à l'assemblée
je trouve je suis très étonné des
réticences que j'ai découverte en même
temps que certains d'abord je voudrais
dire à nos collègues députés qui ont
quelques réticences qu'on me cite un
exemple qu'on nous cite un seul exemple
où la région aurait fait preuve soit
d'irresponsabilité soit d'esprit
partisan et que nous n'aurions pas
accompagner un projet qui n'étaient pas
éligibles
on connaît la réponse deuxièmement si
l'on veut que tout cela marche et ce qui
est marche aujourd'hui au fonds
fonctionne sur la base du de la
composition du comité qui existe et qui
est prévue à l'article 4 de la loi aux
points 13
c'est à dire un comité stratégique là on
l'appelle
conseil d'orientation bon au fond on
travaille pour définir les stratégies
dans nos régions pour définir les
orientations
on travaille avec l'ensemble des acteurs
donc nous sommes déjà des praticiens de
ce type de méthode et donc c'est celle
là évidemment qu'il doit ajouter le
maillon manquant qui est celui des
financements s'ajoute pour abonder ce
que disait alain rousset c'est que quand
on compte quand on regarde le cylindre
verticale aujourd'hui de ces de
l'accompagnement financier des
entreprises
on constate quoi et bien que évidemment
comme sa copie grosso modo le mille
feuille institutionnel et bien il ya un
moment donné où évidemment les communes
les communautés de communes n'ont pas
les compétences pour accompagner les
entreprises et que ce savoir faire qui
est devenu celui des régions il faut
évidemment qu'on l'utilisent et en
mettant dans le comité stratégique c'est
en tout cas de nous ce que nous faisons
les principales agglo évidemment qu'ils
doivent nous accompagner évidemment
enfin c'est l'article 4 points 13 en y
ajoutant les élus qui sont chargés avec
nous d'accompagner le développement
économique le pas trop long je finis en
posant deux ou trois questions
donc aujourd'hui par rapport au
dispositif qui existe
tu as cité les fonds que nous avons mis
en place avec quelquefois d'autres
régions nous en haute normandie avec la
basse normandie et la bretagne en a mis
à fond d'amorçage bien il existe aussi
entre normandie capital investissement
capital risque et capital de
développement avec évidemment des fonds
à l'innovation bien là dedans il y a à
la fois des fonds publics
il y à la fois des fonds privés et nous
sommes dans les comités d'engagement
donc va-t-on multiplier mythe et le
territoire régional national de tous ces
outils ou est-ce que l'on va dans ce
projet d'établissement public faire en
sorte que l'on mette ce qui existe en
réseau et qu'on apportera la force de ce
nouvel établissement public en même
temps de manière à ce que
tout cela fonctionne d'un même mouvement
parce qu'au fond l'avantagent dit met
les régions c'est quand même que une
fois que le dossier est complet je
suppose que c'est comme ça dans toutes
les régions
moi je vous garantis dossier complet
deux mois après les crédits sont versés
aux qu aux entreprises qui en ont besoin
et j'insiste beaucoup que ce dispositif
doit évidemment j'ai dit tout au long de
la vie de l'entreprise y compris donc à
l'export où notre pratique fait que l'on
mutualisent l'ensemble des pratiques et
que l'on met à la disposition des pme un
réseau auquel ils n'ont pas spontanément
accès et que tout cela doit reposer sur
le conventionnement entreprises
collectivités avec le chef de file à de
la région donc nous ce que nous
réclamons fond ce n'est pas d'exercer un
pouvoir que nous n'avons pas c'est que
cette cohérence et cette pratique soit
mise au service des entreprises et du
développement économique et que lorsque
areva renault viennent dans mon bureau
accompagné quelques fois des présidents
des deux agglos ou quand le président de
cci international vient me demander de
contribuer avec lui à l'élaboration
d'une politique à l'export
ça veut dire que dans toutes les têtes
je dis pas bien pensante dans toutes les
têtes qui sont dans le champ du
développement économique
évidemment il est naturel que 7 des pays
qui est attendu soit conforme aux
espoirs que l'on que l'on met en elle
merci merci monsieur le président si
vous voulez bien répondre c'est trop
premier puis après on prendra les prises
de parole oui je crois d'abord je lai un
peu évoquée mais je confirme aujourd'hui
que si l'on veut répondre aux besoins
des entreprises il faut qu'on améliore
l'offre de la dette d'emprunt ce que les
contraintes de bâle iii aujourd'hui sont
extrêmement dramatique et une rétraction
de l'offre considérable et le
fonctionnement de zéo aujourd'hui est
lié
à l'intervention d'une banque privée
dire qu'au départ on avait dit à oséo
pour qu'il joue un effet de levier
vous vous pousser une banque privée
intervenir aujourd'hui c'est le
phénomène inverse comme il faut que la
banque privée interviennent oseo
n'intervient pas donc il faudra
peut-être d'ailleurs dans l'organisation
de la banque concret une structure qui
fasse qu'oseo puisse un certain qu'à
intervenir d'une manière faute
j'ajoute à cela je le dis sans pour
avoir bousculé beaucoup discuté avec les
responsables de cdc entreprises et du et
du fsi que je trouve que souvent le fsi
ou cdc entreprises demandent des
théories exorbitants exorbitants j'ai le
cas d'une e t il dans ma région c'est
entre 15 à 25%
c'est pas acceptable c'est pas
acceptable
il y avait une étude qui avait été faite
par l'ancien patron de l'en var jeu dont
j'ai oublié le nom à terre du moment où
qui disait qu'à partir du moment où la
banque était publique
certes elle ne vais pas rentrer dans le
rouge et il fallait qu'on soit attentif
à ce que le retour ne soit pas ne soit
pas exorbitant je confirme ce ce qu'a
dit alain le vern gelé un peu dit tout à
l'heure on a les régions une partie de
une partie de la solution sur les pme
les aides directes les avances
remboursables les aides à l'innovation
les aides à la formation
on a besoin d'eux on a besoin de la
banque d'offres bancaires on a besoin
d'eux on a besoin de deux offres en
capital en capitaux risques capitaux
risqueurs et donc il faut qu'on
établisse dans chaque région je pense
pas que ça soit mise en cause des
plateformes non pas qu'ils soient des
guichets uniques je me méfie de ce terme
parce que quand on fait des guichet
unique c'est le guichetier quel pouvoir
si j'ose dire et on crée des des
phénomènes d'encombrement des petits
pouvoirs dont simplement pour guider et
orienter vers la bonne structure et que
la pme est une réponse globale et
que l'avait pays pourra mettre en place
de réelles politiques je souhaite les
députés ont été très punchy sur la
transition énergétique sur le numérique
sur l'économie sociale et solidaire sûr
je voudrais pas qu'on se répartissent
d'ores et déjà les les morceaux de la
bpi il appartient à la région et la
gestion des crédits européens qu'on va
lui confier les obligera à mettre en
place des stratégies industrielles
il ya des stratégies industrielles
nationales et les stratégies
industrielles régionales notamment quand
il ya beaucoup de sous-traitants dans
dans une région où des secteurs
particuliers dans ce domaine je reviens
aux différents textes en m'interrogeais
sur le son la composition des ce et rohs
les comités régionaux jeu j'aurais mieux
aimé que l'on dise il appartient au
président du conseil régional et au
président du conseil économique et
social de déterminer la liste les des
membres de deux là se réserve de la
parité du comité régional d'orientation
parce que nos régions sont différents
parce qu'il ya une diversité de tissu
industriel d'organisations syndicales de
jouets préférés
je veux pas être soumis à des vengeances
en entrant dans mon assemblée donc là
aussi je m'en remets à votre votre votre
sagacité
mais je souhaite qu'il soit inscrit que
le président que le président du conseil
régional soit le président du ce du
comité d'orientation régionale ça ça me
semble être être quelque chose
d'important
voilà j'ai pas répondre à d'autres
questions mais en vous écoutant monsieur
le président une réflexion va donner la
parole à monsieur châtillon vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure que 90% des
engagements devaient être au niveau
régional mais qu'il est lâchement
- la place de l'état stratège vis-à-vis
des filières ou ses coordonnées entre
l'échelon régional et l'échelon national
bon je passe je réponds à votre question
parce qu'elle est important c'est trop
d'honneur monsieur mais elle est
importante parce que je pense que c'est
une question de 2 c'est une question de
2 comment dire de compréhension globale
des dossiers commander les régions
auront à structurer des filières
industrielles à l'échelle de la région
l'état va le faire
l'état peut dire aujourd'hui pourrait
dire devrait dire je me lance dans une
stratégie par exemple sur le stockage de
l'énergie comme le font les allemands et
japonais
je pense qu'il va le faire stockage de
l'énergie c'est la condition de base
pour développer les énergies
renouvelables
ce sont des énergies alternatives
aléatoires donc il faut et c'est une
technologie compliqué sas le no log la
forêt se dire je me lance dans une
stratégie avec là une forme de cohérence
que je mène avec l'inserm sur le passage
du médicaments chimiques aux médicaments
biotechnologiques
ça c'est une on peut dire ils le font je
me lance dans le passage de la fission
nucléaire à la fusion nucléaire qui est
jose
c'est cadarache
gk l'arraché puis le barp en aquitaine
parce que et à une technologie qui avait
été oublié et que la région aquitaine
finance actuellement avec le surf je dis
ça à titre clin d'oeil mais en tout cas
ça c'est des stratégies nationales
quel est le devenir d'ariane 5 est-ce
que c'est ariane 6 est ce que c'est rien
de 5eme
on sait régler d'après l'accord semaine
dernière non il faut lille mais
transitoire mme transitoirement bonbons
qu'on sur le plan territorial
alain le vern évoqué tout à l'heure la
discussion avec areva
je me trouve exactement comme lui quand
une entreprise importante de ma région
je pense à snecma par exemple ou safran
me dit est ce que vous pouvez m'aider
pour inventer les arrières corps du
moteur de demain plus léger qui ball
mieux qu'ils prennent ce qu'ils envoient
moins de hendrix et que c'était donc jeu
qu'on finance la recherche
mais derrière le deal c'est vous
transférez le business aux pme que vous
choisissez et on restructure le tissu de
pme pour les faire grossir
c'est ça la politique industrielle la
région moi quand j'arrive en aquitaine
en 98 il ya plus de recherche sur la
vigne et le vin tout est parti donc j'ai
reconstitué un un centre de recherche
sur la vigne et le vin à part le no lo j
en avais a laissé tous partir ils ont
tout vu c'est parce qu'il avait tout dit
et s'écrit il avait oublié plein de
choses mais il était tellement content à
bordeaux d'avoir le meilleur vin du
monde quoi qu'ils avaient oublié un
certain nombre de choses non mais gérard
m'a soutenu l'issue donc voilà on a des
stratégies régionales à mettre à mettre
en place ce qui va arriver à la banque
c'est quoi c'est parfois les résultats
d'un appel d'offres que la région aura
lancé pour dire comment je numérise le
patrimoine commenge regroupe
l'entreprise donc il y aura un peu de
fonds propres purs un peu de preuves
voilà et puis ça peut être ça va être
aussi parce que je n'aime pas ce mot
il faut être opportuniste je veux dire
les entreprises elles sont dans des
stratégies aussi de développement il
faut on aura à la fois 60 à 70% de
filières et on aura 30 à 40% d'émergence
d'entreprises qui sont chauds nos
territoires
l'agroalimentaire il reste peut être
encore une petite entreprise de tissage
ici on va peut-être constituer autour du
cuir moi j'ai des entreprises de cuir de
luxe
en dordogne ils ont ils avaient perdu
tout le tout la chaussure mais ça c'est
ça s'est développé
voilà donc l'état l'état là-dessus
l'état là-dessus n'a pas intervenir
l'état voit voit tout le tout le
surgissement d'affaires c'est à la
région de 2,2 me pousser tout ça ok
monsieur on fait ça de parler
d'agroalimentaire monsieur châtillon
supposée d'armes écouter dans l'habitude
de travailler ensemble le président o c
tant au niveau de l'irdi depuis un
certain nombre d'années qu'au niveau du
pôle de compétitivité des pôles de
compétivité dans le tire donc sa culture
industrielle je la partage le vrai
problème pour moi c'est la simple la
simplicité dans tous les dispositifs
complexes
ça marche pas la première question je
veux su poser c'est est-ce que c'était
utile de regrouper oseo qui marche bien
le fsi qui a son autonomie aujourd'hui
et qui fonctionne bien
cdc entreprises est-ce que la bpi ne
pouvait pas s'appliquer sur un tissu
comme cela a été indiqué la fois
régionale avec la caisse des dépôts et
faire en sorte qu on fasse fonctionner
ce développement régional la deuxième
question c'est est-ce que la taille de
nos régions nécessite une implication de
l'ensemble des régions est ce qu'il faut
pas manger un peu les régions
pardonnez-moi regrouper un petit peu les
régions pour avoir des landers française
ou des régions comme cela existe en
espagne
c'est ce que nous faisons je crois que
c'est un bon exemple entre midi-pyrénées
et l'aquitaine dans les domaines des
pôles de compétitivité et dans le
domaine de l'accompagnement financier et
la troisième question c'est est ce qu'il
est vraiment utile pour 10% dans une
filiale de faire rentrer les banques
privées est ce que au contraire
ne devons-nous pas être autonome de ses
banques pour les obliger ensuite à
participer pourquoi leur transmettre des
dossiers qui seront plus ou moins abondé
ou pas bondée où le plus souvent
concurrence et j'ai vécu ça avec l'irdi
à sa création avec alain savary
lorsqu'en face nous avions tous face au
teil banquiers venait trenet de dossiers
et faisait surenchère dès le lendemain
donc je crois que c'est pas une bonne
chose de faire rentrer les banquiers
privés
à ce stade là dedans une filiale de
filiale colas b trois questions donc
simplification coordination pouvoir
régional accompagnement des entreprises
des pôles de compétitivité
madame madame cherche urgent
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président de région
aujourd'hui à votre avis la bpi at elle
des ressources suffisantes pour assurer
sa mission comme vous l'avez d'ailleurs
décrite auprès des entreprises
ou faut-il je vous demande votre avis
irrigué de l'épargné populaire comme par
exemple l'assurance vie ou le doublement
du livret a pour abonder des ressources
pour faire en sorte que cette bpi est
vraiment les moyens pour être un réel
levier c'est une question que je vous
pose
à votre avis la bpi doit être la banque
du tissu économique des territoires
est ce qu'il ne serait pas bon non plus
que cette baie pays soit rayé et
bénéficie de l'expertisé de la banque de
france et sous quelle forme à ce moment
là on pourrait l'organiser
troisième question à votre avis est-ce
que pour les entreprises bénéficiaires
il ne faudrait pas inclure des critères
sociaux tels que les conditions de
travail la formation prévue dans cette
entreprise
la représentation des salariés et des
critères environnementaux c'est à dire
comment cette entreprise
participe-t-elle à la transition
énergétique dont nous parlons temps en
ces temps et dernière question avez vous
pratiqué puisque les régions une belle
expertise
le contrôle a posteriori des aides
financières est ce une pratique ou
est-ce qu'il faut maintenant vraiment
pas cela
vitesse supérieure pour contrôler les
aides qui sont donnés à ces entreprises
vraiment aller aller jusqu'au bout car
ce sont des aides publiques et quels
moyens on pourrait se donner dans cette
gouvernance pour que les entreprises se
sentent liés aux territoires et aux élus
qui ont aux institutions aux
institutions telles que le conseil
régional donc qui a affecté ses fonds je
m'exprime al le contrôle souvent
échappent à postériori c'était
entreprises ont bénéficié de l'aide
publique et non pas suffisamment mon
avis de comptes à rendre
est-ce qu'on peut obliger dans cette
baie pays que des comptes soient demandé
plus de façon plus serrée auprès de ces
entreprises
michel teston messieurs les présidents
sur le président rousset vous avez fait
part de vos remarques
certaines critiques sur ce qui est prévu
en matière de gouvernance et de
structuration de la banque publique
d'investissement je souhaite profiter de
l'occasion qui m'est donnée de dire qu'à
mon sens la place des régions au sein
des banques lui des investissements doit
être en cohérence avec la place que le
gouvernement entend donner aux régions
dans le cadre de la future réforme
territoriale qui doit en principe leur
donner un rôle majeur en matière de
développement économique avec les
schémas régionaux développement
économique et donc je plaide pour qu il
ya une grande cohérence entre les
orientations stratégiques dans la banque
publique d'investissement et par
ailleurs la stratégie de chaque région
en matière de la économique ça me
paraîtrait tout à fait cohérent je pense
que c'est la bonne approche qu'il
faudrait avoir dès le départ je ne pense
pas monsieur le président que vous ne
contredirait mais si vous voulez me
contredire n'hésitez pas
merci monsieur le président il ya
l'idéal qui pourrait être d'imaginer
effectivement de grandes régions
probablement plus plus efficace et puis
elle réelle c'est-à-dire la volonté la
nécessité d'intervenir au plus tôt
compte tenu de la situation de
traversons il ya un engagement qui a été
pris par le président de la république
de création de banque publique
d'investissement parce qu'il y avait une
nécessité parce que rappelons le quand
même le système bancaire et financier
traditionnel n'avait pas joué le rôle
qui aurait dû être le sien aussi on
entend dire parfois que finalement la
caisse des dépôts et consignations et
oseo sont habitués bien entendu à
travailler à soutenir les petites et
moyennes entreprises et qu'elles sont
d'une grande efficacité quand on sait
qu'on se croit pas l'utilité qu'il y
aurait à créer la banque publique
d'investissement
c'est faux parce qu'en pleine période de
crise même si les contacts et les
liaisons
on était étroite et parfois efficace
avec la caisse des dépôts que sur les
consignations et d'oseo ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas et vous évoquez tout
à l'heure le problème de la sous
traitance dans l'aéronautique pour
évoquer le problème de la sous traitance
dans la construction navale après la
crise de 2007 2008 2008
et c'est du même ordre et si les
conseils régionaux ce moment là n'était
pas intervenu à la fois plus rapidement
plus efficacement pour soutenir ces
petites et moyennes entreprises
elle serait plus là aujourd'hui alors
qu'elle avait uniquement un creux dans
dans leurs commandes donc il ya
nécessité impérieuse de création de
cette banque publique d'investissement
une fois qu'on a dit cela on voit bien
et vous l'avez évoqué vous même qui a
une réticence que nous constatons
parfois au niveau des départements
parfois au niveau des métropoles avoir
les régions s'impliquer trop fortement
dans les prises de décision de la banque
publique d'investissement donc pour être
efficace je pense que
on doit passer automatiquement par une
case qui consiste à convaincre et à
rassurer donc comment faire pour
convaincre et rassurer à la fois des
départements ou des parties de
département voire des métropoles qui
sont inquiètes
si ce sont les régions qui sait les
sentiments qu'ils éprouvent en tout cas
qu'ils évoquent décide décide de tout et
si le territoire global des départements
est insuffisamment pris en compte
c'est ce qui est évoqué et donc pour
éviter cela est ce qu'il ne serait pas
possible de faire un certain nombre de
propositions faisant que les assemblées
départementales les métropoles voir des
parties de départements communautés de
communes soit représentée au sein des
instances de décisions pour autant cela
ne signifie pas que la région ne joue
pas pleinement son rôle je suis
convaincu que ce sont aux régions compte
tenu précisément de ce qui vient d'être
souligné dès lors que dans la troisième
phase de décentralisation il est prévu
que le développement économique vos
régions
il ya une logique est imparable c'est
que les financements également de nos
tissus industriels notamment des pme
pour qu'elles deviennent des outils
soient aussi sous la responsabilité des
régions lorsqu'il s'agit de prendre des
décisions mais il faut rassurer et je
pense que cette étape-là est
indispensable sans quoi si nous ne
parvenant pas il ya fort à craindre que
ce soit finalement recentraliser il se
soit aperçu au bout du compte qu'ils
soient vainqueurs de la différence des
oppositions des différentes
collectivités territoriales et donc pour
éviter cela je pense qu'il est
indispensable de rassurer deuxième point
pour assurer en termine est ce que vous
ne pensez pas qu'il serait intéressant
de d'évoquer système d'évaluation après
une année par exemple de fonctionnement
pour bien montrer que à la fois les
régions prennent ça à bras le corps
parce que c'est efficace parce que c'est
plus opérants mais qu'en même temps les
autres collectivités territoriales
peuvent être
associer parce que c'est rassurant et
aussi pour voir si le sujet est évoqué
précédemment
s'il n'y a pas opposition entre les
stratégies industrielles décidé
nationalement et des stratégies
industrielles qui pourrait être
différente au niveau régional ça ce
n'est pas possible bien entendu
donc il faut rassurer je pense à la fois
certain nombre d'administrations de
l'état est aussi et des responsables
départementaux et de métropole monsieur
de nice
deux questions premièrement est-ce que
vous pensez que dans les missions de la
banque publique d'investissement il
conviendrait que de façon explicite et
un texte soit mentionné l'économie
sociale et solidaire premiers éléments
deuxième question je un peu dans le sens
des différents échanges que nous avons
eus sur nécessité de calage de 7 des
pays de ces organisations par rapport à
un nouvel acte de la décentralisation
est ce que nous paraît pas opportun
quand on sait que financements publics
aux alentours de 70 milliards
je pense yves prend les chiffres 2009
ces 12 pour les régions 17 et demi les
départements 39 et quelques le bloc
communal intercommunale est-ce que de
l'investissement public un jeu par la
sueur languereau les 70 milliards
il y à 15 milliards qui sont portées par
les systèmes d écoute de l'économie
mixte des spl des sem
est-ce que nous paraîtrait pas opportun
premièrement que la fédération de ses
entreprises publiques locales soit
présente au comité d'orientation au
niveau national d'une part et au niveau
régional d'autre part de façon à ce
qu'on puisse avoir le maillage dont il
était question précédemment sans qu'il
n'y ait obligatoirement de
représentation institutionnelle du type
métropole départementaux qui serait un
maquiller qui serait me semble t'il un
peu compliqué à gérer dans les choix et
dans les lisibilité de représentation et
qui pourrait atteindre un compromis de
bon aloi
gb bat la dordogne oui c'est une seule
question c'est sur la problématique de
la gouvernance bon travail ensemble
anne aquitaine et notamment en dordogne
c'est vrai que le conseil régional
d'aquitaine de piqûre il a un président
qui s'appelle rousset à une politique je
dirais en matière industrielle et
économique lisible des interventions qui
accompagne le travail qui est fait sur
le terrain même un peu innovante je
pense avant l'heure aujourd'hui on est
en train de travailler sur le
développement numérique et on avait en
2004 déjà un schéma qui a été mis en
place en aquitaine dont j'ai bénéficié
donc moi je suis en parfaite cohérence
avec ce qui est décidé aujourd'hui ma
question simplement un problème de
gouvernance et j'aimerais que le
président alain rousset puis ce
l'illustré à travers sa connaissance de
l'aquitaine et de la dordogne
comment et ça ça fait écho à ce que
vient de dire yannick vaugrenard comment
on intègre en matière de gouvernance à
partir de l'outil qu'est régionales je
suis d'accord les collectivités que sont
le conseil général qui joueront là
dessus et les contenus d'agglo
éventuellement les communautés de
communes parce que la proximité c'est ce
qui me semble le plus important c'est
eux qui sont à même de détecter
d'accompagner les entreprises elles le
font à travers un certain nombre de
mesures d'investissement qui sont
accompagnés et relié qui sera accompagné
par le conseil régional dont j'aimerais
voir un peu comment tu vois à l'échelle
régionale
cette gouvernance ce partenariat est ce
qu'il est institutionnalisée est ce qui
n'est pas institutionnaliser avec les
collectivités locales de proximité
merci je voulais simplement dire à notre
collègue marc denis sq
article 1er paragraphe 8 explicitement
l'économie sociale et solidaire et dans
le texte par rapport à la question posée
ensuite monsieur mirassou oui au risque
de répéter ce qui a été dit par
plusieurs de mes collègues avant moi je
pense que la préoccupation qui est
affiché et qui est complètement
satisfaisante qui consiste à dire qu'il
serait impensable que l'avènement de la
bpia même temps tout ce que ça suppose
en termes de stratégie industrielle doit
être complètement connecté à cette
fameuse troisième phase de
décentralisation
parce qu en quelque sorte la gestion
d'un pays va officialiser la montée en
puissance de savoir faire au niveau
régional qui préexiste depuis maintenant
au moins deux décennies donc
l'organisation ensuite entre ce qui se
passe en termes stratégie industrielle à
l'échelon national et éventuellement une
déclinaison à l'échelle régionale ne
doit pas être pour autant trop
contraignantes
parce que autant de régions autant de
particularités et donc il faudra dans
cette fameuse cette fameuse
structuration donner les possibilités de
de respiration la question que je me
pose c'est de savoir quelle va être la
ligne de démarcation quelque sorte entre
ce qui relève véritablement des
compétences et du ressort de la lépi
internet issement pour pâques en quelque
sorte créé un effet d'aubaine par
rapport aux banques privées dont on a vu
notamment l'occasion de la crise
bancaire que malgré l'injection massive
de capitaux émanant de l'état fidèle je
serai tel de vie à leur habitude l ont
pas voulu prendre le moins de risques
alors j'imagine que si à l'échelon
régional avait pays fonctionne au niveau
des entreprises éligibles par le biais
de critères qui passe justement par
cette femme une structuration de
filières sans pour autant négliger ce
qu'on avait dit président sur quelques
niches où quelques particularismes
locaux qui mérite aussi d'être épaulé je
me demande comment on pour arriver à
éviter cet écueil
nommons la prise de risque je veux dire
les banques privées qui parle à aller
voir la bpi moi c'est un souci que j'ai
ça merci monsieur joël labbé oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de l'assemblée des régions est
venue quelque part plaidé la place des
régions dans la gouvernance et je crois
que c'est pleinement pleinement légitime
mais qui a nécessité d'avoir une
stratégie nationale
on y arrivera avec l' équilibre
justement entre le rôle de l'état d'un
stratégie nationale et puis l'importance
des régions leur savoir-faire leur
expertise concernant les équilibres
régionaux
il y a les régions plus rurales qui ne
bénéficient que de peu de développement
comment faire en sorte que la banque
publique d'investissement soit un un des
leviers dans ce sens là et d'autre part
on est en situation de nécessaires
mutations économiques
comment faire en sorte que la banque
publique d'investissement soit aussi
levier pour aller dans ce sens là et
avait il yal se posera quand même la
question des moyens comme l'a soulevé
tout à l'heure notre collègue mirail
cherche on a eu quelques chiffres
simplement 3% des fonds de dd fonds
d'assurance-vie fléchés vers la bpi
permettrait d'en doubler les moyens
voilà je vous remercie que de questions
mais passionnante
alors est ce pertinent d'en assembler
oséo le fsi et cdc entreprises
je crois que la réponse est oui sans en
faire un monstre c'est pour ça qu'il
faut la décentraliser aujourd'hui les
entreprises galère trop pour répondre
vite à leurs besoins de financement
et on ne mesure pas à quel point
l'accélération du temps de décision
économique est un des problème de
différenciation entre l'allemagne les
états unis et la france
en france avec le modèle jacobin on met
une année parfois avant d'avoir la
réponse à sa demande de financement
moi j'ai une entreprise du bois 170
personnes
ça fait un an qu'elle est sûre le une
demande d'augmentation de capital
donc c'est râpé elle vient de m'envoyer
un texto hier en disant en même temps la
pme en question a des torts parce que
elle elle n'a pas suffisamment structuré
son staff
donc le job de financement n'est pas
suffisant il faut qu si on accompagne
les entreprises dans leur croissance
je rencontre beaucoup moins
d'entreprises et je pense qu'alain le
vern
le vit aussi où passer d'une pme de 30
personnes ou avec la secrétaire de
direction vous faites tous et qu'à un
moment donné il vous faut absolument un
bureau de recherche développement et un
responsable export est d'ailleurs parmi
les conditionnalité des aides sur
lesquels je suis en train de réfléchir
en tant que président de l'aquitaine
c'est de dire à partir d'un certain
niveau d'entreprise je vous aide si vous
me montrez que vous avez un bureau de
recherche développement et vous avez un
responsable export
parce que bon on a besoin s'ils
voulaient ya parmi tous les défis de
l'entreprise je pense que vous allez
partager ça
et peut-être un des défis les plus
importants c'est le problème de
l'organisation de l'entreprise le
l'appareil productif français et vieux y
compris dans sa tête et dans son
organisation
il ya un enjeu de 2 de croissance de la
productivité qui est fabuleux
avant de parler de la compétitivité
coûts de réorganisation des process de
production de staff de l'entreprise de
responsabilisation des salariés de
travail en îlots de faial moi je vais
lancer en aquitaine un projet dans ce
sens parce que vraiment on a pris du
retard
donc pourquoi oseo fsi s'est laissé je
pense je pense quand même qu'aujourd'hui
l'entreprise elle aurait besoin d'avoir
une plate forme et puis qu'après on lui
voit la l1 dossier et on lui traite le
bout de subventions de la région qui va
bien
l'embauché de quatre qui va bien la
garantie qui va bien les fonds propres
etc voilà qu'on qu'on puisse organiser
le suivi de l'entreprise et je crois que
le monde bancaire aujourd'hui la
différence du monde bancaire de
californie qui a beaucoup développé ça
ça monde un peu financier pas cette
technolog je le maintiens qu'on
comprenne ce qu'est le business le
produit qui qui se développe
et puis il ya une masse critique aussi
un ça va faire 30 à 40 milliards
supplémentaires qui vont nous permettre
avec l' équilibre fonds propre épargne
de pouvoir mettre un peu plus d'argent
alors qu'il ya une rétraction des
crédits les entreprises donc je pense
que c'est mieux
ce qu'il ne faudrait pas par contre vous
avez regardé la presse ces derniers
temps c'est que oseo structure faîtière
met la main sur le dispositif des fonds
propres
voilà donc ça je pense qu'il faut que
vous ayez lorsque le ministre sera
présent faux le questionner on l'a fait
à l'assemblée nationale sur le fait que
l' on propose bien à l'entreprise à la
fois des prêts des garanties de la
d'export etc mais aussi des fonds
propres
nos entreprises n'ont pas assez ouvert
leur capital et aujourd'hui quand elles
ouvrent leur capital c'est parfois
contraints et forcés avec parfois des
fonds d'investissement un peu rapace qui
viennent piquer les clients et la
technologie et qui s'en vont les sens au
territoire et nous avions fait perdre
des compétences
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a une petite
révolution intellectuelle à gauche et à
droite à avoir nous dans notre pays en a
refusé trop longtemps les fonds de
pension si nous avions les fonds de
pension en france nous n'aurions pas les
problèmes de fond d'investissement
cannibale venus de l'étranger pas son
pardon de dire ça c'est pour ça qu'on a
à l'assurance-vie et il faut qu'on
réfléchisse l'assurance vie comme un
fonds de pension nos entreprises ont
aujourd'hui paye parfois avec des
retours et les théories considérable les
retraites des veuves californienne moi
j'ai rien contre les veuve californienne
ou singapour rien je préfère que dire
qu'on développe l'emploi dans nos rangs
et tout ce qui va avec dans nos
territoires sur la taille des régions je
ne suis pas d'accord je suis pas
d'accord la coopération des régions
alain le vern disait bon vous êtes comme
moi voisin de l'aragon rappelez moi
combien d'habitants en aragon deux
millions d'habitants
c'est à dire 30 % - et midi pyrénées et
la navarre
six cent mille habitants six fois moins
que l'aquitaine un budget 6 fois
supérieure quand on va aux fêtes de
pampelune tout pompe l'une est éclairée
chauffer rafraîchir avec des énergies
renouvelables c'est un problème de
moyens c'est pas un problème de taille
d'ailleurs les lattes la taille moyenne
des régions françaises la taille moyenne
des régions allemandes
le land de hambourg 1 million 800 mille
habitants est capable on est allé le
voir avec martin malvy d'accompagner les
pme avec des aides à l'innovation deux
fois ce capitaine et midi-pyrénées
pourtant on avance mais tu es en deux
ans quand vous voulez vous que nos pme
résiste à la compétition européenne
si nous nous avons encore une fois et ça
c'est quelqu'un m'a posé la question sur
la décentralisation
le vrai problème de la décentralisation
c'est qu'on dise qui fait quoi qu'on
n'ait pas besoin d'avoir des directs
qu'on n'ait pas besoin d'avoir des
structures d'état va la france est le
seul pays à garder un système
napoléonien mes chers collègues
un système qui date de napoléon et on a
tous besoin quand on est sur les
territoires d'avoir un petit sous préfet
sous la main bon il nous apporte rien et
ils nous empêchent de structure et
l'intercommunalité
en vain bah oui parce que eh bien oui
j'ai l'air si on était responsable est
ce qu'on a besoin d'avoir enfin quand
même
est ce qu'on a besoin d'avoir partout en
doublons triplons des compétences des
collectivités locales des fonctionnaires
d'état est ce qui serait pas mieux dans
la justice dans la police ou dans
l'éducation
comment voulez vous que nos concitoyens
s'ils reconnaissent et que nous soyons
responsables
si chaque fois il faut se mettre 4
autour de la table pour décider d'une
même chose ça s'appelle la
déresponsabilisation
ça s'appelle tanguy voilà ça c'est
dégagé je sais comme comprenez pourquoi
je suis là ministre de la
décentralisation m bien la cdc i qui
décide et non le préfet de la carte
intercommunale enfin le m enfin tant
attendu je vais vous dire moi j'ai trop
vécu parce que quand j'étais maire j'ai
été chaque fois qu'il ya un projet
d'intercommunalité
rappelez-vous le congrès des maires à
l'intercommunalité forcée
chaque fois un moment donné on devrait
dire l'intercommunalité doit être
suffisamment structurante pour avoir les
services publics pour avoir ce qu'il
faut et puis vous vous mettez d'accord
point barre dentelles de l'assemblée et
le sénat devrait dire ça mais si on va à
dîner le samedi soir à la sous
préfecture ou à la préfecture
ben ma foi on n'avance pas trop je suis
assez radical là dessus monsieur le
président je souhaite que ce soit pas au
procès dans val
je suis ok les cultures différentes
suivant les régions
oui oui complètement mai mais bon moi je
vais pas pourquoi on a fait les pays
pourquoi on a fait les pays parce que
les intercoms était trop petit
maintenant je suis prêt enfin la france
a la moitié des communes d'europe
et oui non si tu supprimes les pays du
sud prime toute cohérence c'est pas toi
qui vas me dire ça bien géré a alors les
banques privées on est d'accord
les banques privées simplement ce que je
disais tout à l'heure je sais plus qui
m'a posé la question
les banques privées il faut bien qu'à un
moment donné on partage le risque ce qui
faut arriver à faire c'est qu'il n'y a
pas d'un côté un effet de levier et et
de l'autre côté un effet de substitution
parce que moi j'ai remarqué quand on
fait les calculs on nous demande
d'intervenir beaucoup au niveau des
régions en garantie garantie pour les
fonds propres en garantie pour les
banques et quand vous regardez le
montant de nos garanties
ce qui d'ailleurs explique notre
responsabilité on arrive à 70 à 80% ce
qui fait que si la banque a des
problèmes mais en même temps je pense
qu'il faut cela ouais on va voir comment
ça va fonctionner un certain nombre de
régions sont en train de réfléchir à ce
qu'on appelle un service public bancaire
qui pourrait être complémentaire de la
bpi et qui auquel le droit européen
donne la possibilité qui est de faire un
appel d'offres un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt dans les régions et de dire
voilà je je cherche un réseau bancaire
qui va m'accompagner particulièrement
des pme en plus de la banque publique ou
en substitution de la banque publique et
moi région haute normandie je les
garanties donc on va voir comment les
choses vont se passer mais on a encore
le droit européen permet à cinq pays
européens qui l'ont développé sur alors
sur le problème de l' épargne populaire
suis exprimé je veux dire c'est un vieux
dossier qu'on amène
le premier initiateur de sas a été alain
savary en midi pyrénées quand il a créé
mardi avec un certain nombre de
collègues
moi j'ai essayé de le faire parce que
j'avais les responsabilités en aquitaine
je me suis fait faucher en rase campagne
par le les banques de la place créer une
structure pour les fonds propres des
entreprises
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi le
modèle allemand fonctionne bien parce
qu'il ya une liaison directe des
épargnants val entreprises les
épargnants voient là où valence avec
l'acceptation du risque
ce que la valeur d'une entreprise elle
peut faire 50 et descendre à 25
donc il faut qu'à un moment donné il ya
un minimum de garanties faut qu' il faut
que cette épargne qui devient du capital
soient rémunérés il faut qu'on fasse une
petite révolution culturelle sur la
transformation de l'épargnant capital
capital doit pas être un gros mot chers
collègues je pense qu'il faut qu'on se
fasse notre petite révolution
moi je suis de ceux qui poussent ses
amis les citoyens investir dans
l'entreprise sauf que serait la veuve de
carpentras elles peuvent investir 30000
euros dans de l'assurance-vie placés en
actions pour son petit fils pour les
études de son petit-fils ou pour eux si
du jour au lendemain ses 30000 euros
deviennent 15000 faut se poser cette
question
voilà la banque de france on travaille
avec elle systématiquement n'y a pas de
seuil il ya des expertises qui est fait
donc ya pas de la conditionnalité on
s'interroge
bien sûr on avance un peu sous cette
conditionnalité faut faire attention
parce que vous avez une pme de 30
personnes
si vous lui dites tendues
vos salaires c'est-à-dire faisant
attention aussi à faire en sorte que ce
choix plutôt le rôle du syndicat mais en
tout cas moi je commence à regarder leur
équilibre des salaires hommes femmes
je m'intéresse à la stratégie de
l'entreprise
j'avais une entreprise en aquitaine qui
étaient scotchés sur du travail à façon
pour dassault et pour les garde côtes
américains et je lui ai dit à un moment
donné je ne vous est plus si vous ne
réinvestissent et pas vous ne
transformez pas votre entreprise et si
vous n'avez pas un bureau de recherche
développement et un ingénieur chargé de
l'export
je pense qu'il faut qu'on regarde ça
nous dans les régions quand on aide les
entreprises quand on les aide à croître
à partir du moment où elle ne se
structure pas elle ne se staff pas voilà
on attend décentralisation ce serait
très long mon cher collègue a coûté 7
on le voit bien même si je suis assez je
pense que c'est la préparation qui a dû
faire alain le vern évoque président et
le rapporteur
je me sens assez à ses dents dans ma
famille régionales avec vos questions et
les réflexions qui sont posées et le
sénat représente des collectivités vont
cercles du pouvoir
mais ce avec les régions quand j'ai
quand je regarde la représentation des
élus régionaux dans nos assemblées jeu
j'ai quand même quelques donc je
vraiment continuer mesdames messieurs
elle va avancer la décentralisation
elle va a lancé pour 3 trois raisons
d'abord parce que notre modèle coûte
trop cher aujourd'hui beaucoup trop cher
en matière d'organisation public on peut
plus payer des doublons des tripes long
parce qu'en plus le temps de la décision
publique est trop long comme il faut
mettre d'accord 400 personnes pour des
raisons démocratiques parce qu'on sait
pas qui fait quoi pour des raisons
d'intelligence territoriales parce qu'il
faut qu'on prenne coup faut qu'on se
prenne en main sur des compétences
territoriales à l'état de fixer
l'élégante d'or les grandes compétences
régaliennes la fiscalité etc
vous savez je connais pas un pays qui a
regretté la décentralisation
pas un seul y compris d'ailleurs sur le
plan de l'égalité territoriale
parce que regarder on hurle tous que les
territoires sont pas suffisamment égaux
mais la décentralisation aller au mieux
du chemin on a toujours râler et chaque
fois qu'on a confié des responsabilités
à une région ou un département chaque
fois les inégalités se sont réduites que
ce soit en espagne en allemagne au
portugal partout regardez le limousin
depuis que le limousin à la
responsabilité est bien le déficit qu'il
avait en maison de retraite en maison de
retraite
c'est de la proximité s'est réduit
regardez regardez l'état des lycées
professionnels aujourd'hui regarder
l'état des cfa se dire je crois que
là-dessus a pas que les comités
régionaux d'orientation fasse venir
d'autres collectivités
c'est pour ça que moi je préférerais
qu'il n'y ait pas une liste parisienne
de la composition des comités régionaux
je trouve que ce serait après à chaque
président voilà sur l'économie sociale
et solidaire elle est inscrite
je crois que c'est une bonne initiative
deux de nos collègues de l'assemblée
vous avez évoqué l'effet d'aubaine jeu j
ai répondu tout à l'heure je ne me fais
pas de pardon de le dire sur sur le plan
industriel
je me fais plus de soucis en matière des
prises médical qu'en matière d'emploi
industriel pour une raison très simple
les statistiques montrent que 60 % de
l'emploi industriel est en milieu rural
60%
et qu'il y ait un potentiel de
développement parce qu on ne déplace pas
facilement ses salariés et parce que il
faudrait aller très vite dans la
reconstruction de l'outil industriel
moi j'ai des exemples dans les
pyrénées-atlantiques dans des
entreprises de l'aéronautique qui sont
venus là pendant l'entre-deux-guerres
parce qu'on s'éloignait des frontières
de l'est pendant reconstruite en
totalité
2500 personnes progrès de productivité
100% sans pour ce jeu vous dire en
matière de compétitivité ça donne ça ça
marche donc
donc voilà je me fais pas de souci je me
ferais du souci
si les agglomérations et je vous demande
d'être attentifs les métropoles voulait
maintenir leur souhait dix ans il est
dévolue de plein droit les compétences
de la région et du département aux
métropoles pascal or là on relancerait
une compétition entre les territoires et
alors là il y aura du sang partout
on a à peu près réglé le problème de la
compétition entre les territoires
proches mais vous vous doutez bien que
si une agglomération a la capacité de
mettre sur la table le montant maximum
des aides publiques
la gratuité du bâtiment l'entreprise
elle va se délocaliser à 4 km le gardera
ses salariés mais elle va se délocaliser
soyez attentifs à cela je pense que nos
textes n'est plus
nenê n'est plus de mise c'était la
proposition du du précédent gouvernement
mais on a toujours à l'oeuvre ce type de
demandes créer des villes hanséatiques
qui est tout le pouvoir et après pâques
l'agglomération vous savez j'ai près
j'en ai présidé une réunion en mai mende
moyens pour à l'étranger peut vous
préparer des bâtiments blancs faire des
zones d'activités câble et ses zones
d'activité créer des pépinières
département aussi ce que nous souhaitons
garder au niveau des régions
c'est les aides directes aux entreprises
il est le stratégie régionale où vous
avez besoin de d'un territoire région
sur le médicament sur le bois sur le
haut et ça c'est ça c'est fondamental
parce que on se délocalise à dix mille
kilomètres ou à quatre kilomètres et il
ne faudrait pas que de cette loi sorte
une compétition sur des territoires de
proximité qui mettrait les élus nos
concitoyens et les chefs d'entreprise et
les salariés dans des situations
difficiles
voilà vous venez de suivre une partie de
l'audition d'alain rousset si vous
souhaitez la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
très bonne soirée à tous